but obviously the last two years you've
seen what's been happening with Bill
Maher Bill Mars now like yeah I mean
Bill Maher and he's doing such a great
job and he's doing this that's because
they're clamoring right think about that
for a second they're going oh Bill Maher
says something even remotely
conservative like someone on the
entertainment because they're used to
nothing but talking it's also very easy
to say you know I haven't changed
they've changed that's his yeah
resounding narrative yeah which is
actually true no I think it's complete
horseshit you believe I think it's
complete horseshit because again you're
talking about in 2004 uh when it was
2000 2006 right being banned I remember
being banned from uh I think it was uh
it was it was a marianopolis or was
Concordia like getting into trouble
getting booed having to be like escorted
out of universities having shows
canceled because of things that were
Politically Incorrect back then and at
that point in time all the comedians
said ah this is just you're just making
a big deal up until not too long ago
Bill Maher was hitting those same
talking points so I do think that they
left I don't think the left left them I
do think that both the right have become
more left and the left has become in
increasingly left but if you look at the
things that Bill Maher espouse not too
long ago it was left it was left it was
significantly left from everything from
like I think now unfortunately you have
people revisiting the gay marriage topic
you know why because they have people
going on a second we can't put kids on
puberty blockers like that's a bridge
too far but so everyone has a line now
people realize everyone has a line and
they're going did the line have to be
back there I mean I can't tell you how
many people who used to be liberal have
said you know what I just don't know
where we stopped this and now kids are
being taken away from their parents it's
about in puberty blockers and I remember
with Dave Rubin
um you know who's a friend and he does
my show and I've done a show quite a few
times and he was very surprised back in
the day where you would say like I
didn't leave the left left me Steven you
know that kind of thing and uh he said
like I know like you're more you're more
libertarian like you support same-sex
marriage I said no I don't
because uh it was surprised because when
I see him I give him a big hug you know
I see him I I have a lot of love for the
guy and I think a lot of people think
that if you have an issue politically
with the blurring of gender lines it
means you hate people and I said no
here's the deal and I don't think it's a
fair comparison to interracial marriage
because I think that uh fundamentally
black and white people as parents are
interchangeable if they want to be
present in their children's lives in
other words I do not think that a black
woman is incapable of providing to a
child whom she loves what a white woman
can as a mother I said but I don't think
that two dads can provide what a mother
and father can and I don't think that
two moms can provide what a mother and a
father can I don't think that men and
women are interchangeable as parents as
we could argue people of different races
and I think you're not going to like
where this ends up because to say
they're interchangeable is to say that
uh you know the gender issue that the
gender lines don't exist and that's not
a gay thing that's going into whole new
territory and we're talking about that
maybe in 2016 2015 2017. with Ruben with
Reuben it was surprised and he was
surprised he said okay and I said now
look and you have to understand why
marriage laws exist I wish the
government wasn't in the the marriage
business at all but the reason why was
because before federal government for
state government for they wanted
self-governance and they realized a
nuclear family was the most important
way to do that that's why you have tax
incentives that's why you have the
government recognizing mom and dad and
that's not the same with
Two Dads two moms I think you should
have civil unions all the same rights
but I said this is a slippery slope and
I think that saying men and women are
fundamentally interchangeable will
Target that fabric of society and uh I
don't know who's pushing for that when
we should all be agreeing on the civil
union where do those conversations end
with Reuben
and everything goes down oh he's a super
sweet guy like you're not gonna find the
guy not like sweeter than Dave Rubin
yeah but I think they're surprised
because I think you have to be like a
Westboro Baptist Church person if you go
well there are issues with the same-sex
marriage thing and the beauty is that
you can have your opinion that's what
people always think like he's right no
you could have your opinion you have
your opinion you stick by it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you
[Music]